[Applause]
high risk strategy playing a Scottish
hero doing the Scottish accent filming
in Scotland Scottish actors thanks like
that's a kudos to you yes yeah I mean I
figured I would get crucified by some
people of course I just went full tilt
and tried to tried to do it I had a
wonderful dialect coach we filmed in
Scotland entirely and most of the cast
was Scottish so I had a lot of people
too you know quietly whisper into my ear
I felt I was doing something did you
stay doing the Scottish throughout you
know I did I'm not I don't concern
myself you know I'm the dad not of not
in that regard but just by virtue of the
fact that you're the motor of your mouth
is doing it all day that you find
yourself with the pub later on
especially after a couple of drinks
easily I guess so it's uh it doesn't
feel it's not pretentious and wanky
because you're not you know it is
certainly pretentious and wacky but I
had pretensions away key to them more to
the 40 million people never find
yourself falling back into it random
it's funny I did so with them I it was a
great opportunity so every morning I
would wake up I I'd you know I'd work
out I'd get into the makeup chair and
they'd put this this mullet off my head
yes and I would we would just read
Shakespeare for an hour we just just
read Shakespeare over and we went
through nearly everything so I find
myself if I if I'm look at early reading
Shakespeare just that kind of record
player will you know go back and and
play yes the Scottish accent
[Music]
you
[Music]